you and brendan fraser in in freaking
south africa yeah
you almost died
uh we i think i'm
i don't think i was the only one i mean
we had
we we had armed security uh we weren't
allowed to leave the hotel on our own um
one of the crew cars got shot with like
a
uh ak-740 round because two taxi drivers
got in a fight it was
johannesburg is a very interesting place
and um did you know it was gonna be this
dangerous no
no were you scared for your life at
times i i was i mean i felt protected
because of
the bodyguards the guys around me in the
armored car that i would go to set in
but onset
we would kind of shoot out the in the
boonies a little bit so i didn't feel
like we were a couple times we went into
the city and it it got a little a little
hairy but it added you know i'm trying
to be positive about it now but it added
to the energy of it but the idea when i
went down there is my family would come
and i think within like two days i'm
like you know that's not gonna you're
not coming no and how long were you gone
without seeing them three months without
seeing thompson was that the most
difficult thing you've had to endure
yeah i mean part of it he was and part
of it was he was so young at the time
you know i convinced myself that he
didn't know i wasn't there and my wife
did a great job she ended up flying out
to new york and being with my family
which was helpful as well
um but there were a couple days where it
was really tough but then
you know
most of the time you just focus on the
work and you know
it's just yeah it was tough i won't do
it again how was uh well what do you
mean you won't do it again because the
cw just picked up the professionals to
air on the cw yes now if it's a success
won't they want to do another series
most likely but there'll be some
adjustments to security and location and
duration
what was brendan fraser like to work
with
so
first of all amazing and his career is
just
on a yeah him he's working to take it
off he's working with your buddy
scorsese yeah um
yeah my good buddy scorsese old marty
um i was a fan of brendan
i mean everybody's a fan of brendan and
yeah and we get there and our characters
i'm supposed to play this military guy
who's only paid to protect him and
doesn't really care about him
and his character was written in a way
that should be that way but then brendan
shows up to set and he's so damn likable
and such a nice guy that i found myself
fighting
caring about him as my character would
you know i mean like in person him and i
got along great like it was like it was
seamless but i felt
i i was like i don't think my character
should like him all this much i don't
think he should be so at ease with him
and so it was like a it was like a fun
fight
right but he's just so
he's so good at what he does i mean when
does this air when is the professional's
aaron
they haven't said
but they made an announcement because i
saw the other they bought it they don't
know when they're gonna air it and you
guys should watch the professionals
there's a trailer out for it it looks
pretty crazy it looks like you had it in
an intense shoot we so it doesn't look
like it was fun
it was fun once we started rolling